welcome to this video playing pointe du
jour du jour probably screwing this up
alright so completely form for change
and the bullet Joe I don't really know
the endgame hmm okay maybe that's some
other way to play here yeah I get them
buddy five it's not bleeding too much
isn't there Bishop g5 one of those
strange lines f6 de 590 let's play that
game and I shouldn't have should have
done this a bit quicker of course I only
know that yeah very weakly just from
looking at and it's at some games mostly
for comments for for those big
tournaments but I don't really I don't
really consider myself to be and
knowledgeable about that okay I fix
change this bishop so if I also managed
to exchange of this bishop then this
should be noise
and get f4 going yeah maybe in general
the the main point is that why test is
for against free majority that it's
easier to get going that blacks four
against three but black is no of
concepts exceptionally solid and very
often can set up a blockade I can take
it now but I guess f4 also should be in
order should be okay just intending to
go see 5 f-5 sorry f5 okay
Jim it feels like I have accomplished
something not it's not the end of the
world for frolf or black but then it
should be it should be a little
something mmm yeah but now taking on
your six taking on f5 do I rather play
against the bishop go against the night
and I don't know really I also prefer to
play against the bishop maybe that's
check maybe that's not not correct but I
don't I don't know what I don't know
okay rook f2
I can I can play g4 actually here this
could be good if he takes rook f2 I
think wins the Bishop Bishop d3 rook t2
so he needs to retreat it the question
is yeah maybe he can play a tribe oakley
but I can go with the King all the way
to gym what I thought it wasn't the
stripped oh I'm such a fool he can of
course we treated all the way to h7 what
what was I thinking I can play a five
though how does he how does he secure
the Bishop Bishop yeah but what what on
earth I simply forgot that he can go to
age 7 and secure it okay f5 he plays
what ke samne probably then the bishop
and i still prefer that if the bishop
needs to go somewhere on the queenside
okay
yeah just blended this poem and then
there are still some chances to to fight
maybe you should have one what the heck
am I doing here what the game you just
gotta play Bishop everyone okay yambol I
really deserve to lose it check the only
thing that I can think of in terms of
fighting here maybe here blocking this
h5 and some somehow initiate a
breakthrough on the on the King side at
least the extra porn is this see porn
it's not that's probably like black cat
probably a windows relatively easily I
wonder should I go to c5 here he's maybe
threatening c5 a3c five then takes a 5
i'm giving up yet another pawn come on
if i get to see 5 I don't really know
how black wins this a 5 I take and this
is also very dangerous pawn but now h5
or g5
sure each time warning yeah yeah I know
not so sure about all this she came but
need to increase the speed of it
check check hmm I don't feel like I'm in
big danger anymore really despite being
two pawns down the structure is so
terrible for black here tell me if you
don't think you can do so much here this
the king is scared of here and i can try
to win the queenside pawns maybe I'm
getting too ambitious iam maybe but I
forgot about that little better return
threatening night c5 checkmate that's
funny check e six no it's not on but I
can maybe get c7
no check I wonder if there's some way to
oh just one no I'm winning actually I
think check maybe King 26 I I don't know
okay now i'm winning again check check
check check mate yeah well this was one
of the most undeserved windsor for a
while he could have just won the rook at
one point with bishop f1 the endgame of
ella was a bit tricky and not here
bishop f1 s sir not exactly rocket
science yeah i just played it terribly
bad i just i simply didn't i simply
forgot that he can he can withdraw i
thought i wouldn't i win the bishop I
mean he can just go to age 7 and I
should maybe it would still play that
check leading to a similar structure
than in the game yeah grouped into us of
course I amazing lemon okay but now we
had this end game and I think what what
he did is he he played he played as
pawns in the wrong way shouldn't play b5
this is not not helping leading to this
this blockade and jam here it's
interesting really
maybe yeah my d-force may be debatable
but the thing is I wasn't afraid about
this but I can maybe go here and this is
served quite quite comparable to the
game but he does not have a cc porn hmm
i don't really know if black can win the
spins anymore after he played b5 even
this i don't i don't really see how it
is going to win it if besides a 5 there
is simply no idea anymore for black wii
computer says is equal maybe it is i
mean the check the problem is also that
it is slightly easier for white to plate
you always check have the night now the
night is tricky now that i think of it
if you look at this position i could
also try to go here and then play a six
year or a six in fact immediately would
have been interesting you look at this
it's amazing white still has an
initiative being two points down but his
pants are simply are simply am simply
not very potent him interesting young
and here i mean i don't really risk
anything check just have this blockade
lego you got the porn check when we had
all this check CI a-- played it a plated
probably later gently probably i'm such
I'm so I'm sometimes sometimes I feel
like I should have my brain checked why
my hot playing at seven year it's just
so easy gam a6 King f6 and and I'm going
to make him I love this yeah sometimes
with little time in fact yeah okay Kingy
five is still a win yeah okay sometimes
it's just just just terrible play and
here he can just go here of course and
draw the game he had three at sixteen
seconds yeah well we both played a
really bad game here but it was
interesting to note that despite to pawn
some black has a hard time to win yay
you really shouldn't play b5 and weaken
the c5 square like that it seems to help
wide enormously alright thanks for
watching